ladies and possibly some gentlemen I'm
not going to say why but if you like
yourself some Thor you're going to like
yourself this movie or at least a few
scenes in it for sure
rush is directed by Ron Howard and this
film tells the true tale of rivalries
James Hunt and Niki Lauda formula 1
racers so Thor and Frederick Zola from
inglourious basterds are huge rivals and
they're both forming the 1 racers
they're extremely competitive with each
other and this film tells the tale of
how these guys basically continued to
better themselves over and over again as
they tried to be better than the other
person there are some liberties taken
with the true story from what I
understand that's in basically any movie
that comes out in Hollywood that is
based off a true story but for the most
part this film really had my attention
from scene 1 and largely because of the
performances I thought that Chris
Hemsworth was very very good in this
movie as this guy James Hunt he is
basically like the Iron Man of Formula
One racing he wins his races there are
girls there's drinking he loves it now
this other guy comes along who loves
racing just as much but he is so Stern
and serious about it he's so meticulous
he wants to craft the perfect car he
wants to use mechanics to make a car
better and not just skill on the racing
field and it's actually pretty exciting
Rush is a very interesting film but it's
also a very heartfelt film where you can
really start to feel the passion that
these characters have for racing and
it's not just about their rivalry you
need to see how these characters mature
over time and use the other person to
better themselves and that's one of my
favorite things about this movie
actually is not that it's just like two
babies behind the wheel constantly
complaining about the other person being
better they really honestly used each
other to better themselves and that's
what I liked about it because it wasn't
just some stupid Punk rivalry where they
called each other names and gave each
other dirty looks and everything it was
like two men who really cared so much
about the same thing and they used the
other person to make themselves better
at it and that's one of my favorite
things about this movie is the way that
relationship was portrayed it was really
interesting just to see these characters
clash and that's my favorite part of
this movie were those two characters
because the actors portrayed them so
well daniel bruhl was very good
the film not serve I'm saying that
incorrectly he was definitely the most
intense character in this movie the
character where you really were like wow
dude you are taking this way too far at
times and I got to the point where
certain audience members were even like
squirming in their seat and how serious
these guys were I'm not gonna spoil
anything but just these guys really take
racing seriously and they will go to
certain extremes to be better than the
other person Ron Howard did a pretty
good job with the racing scenes a little
bit of it felt a little too blurry and
sometimes a little too fast cut for me
although there were definitely really
good shots in there there's definitely a
oversaturated look to this movie that
did kind of get on my nerves a few times
but I think Ron Howard did a really good
job with this movie and the acting was
also very good but really the thing that
kept making me interested in this movie
were those two characters and watching
them try to figure out a way to
consistently best the other person and
that was for me the most enjoyable part
of this movie but the fact that I was
actually interested in this movie really
says something because I'm just so not
into Formula One racing at all and I
find that very interesting that I was
into this movie as much as I was and
that's because of the characters and
because the script was definitely well
written the dialogue was good too and
you really just start to care about how
these characters were going to find a
way out of their crazy rivalry and I
really enjoy that about this movie I'm
going to give Rush a B+ so guys thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes
[Music]